welcome to Tech talk we're continuing
our series on open source and I've
invited with us nadden the red hat guy
and I really wanted to follow up on a
question that came up in our recent
video we were talking about open source
and how much people love it
but they asked how do I make money doing
this
and I thought I addressed this in the
video but I mentioned there was a
foundational layer
that you can use then to build business
value in the last percentage and I kind
of alluded to support but maybe I didn't
cover it all too well
being able to charge for that
this is part of the red hat business
model can you kind of elaborate on these
points for our viewers absolutely then
I'm going to start with support support
is something that you really get to you
know when something breaks you want a
foundation and you want to build up on
it and you want to actually secure it
you want to make it Enterprise great
from the get-go what am I talking about
I am talking about going from Project to
product
and what's the difference so when it
comes to product what red hat does is we
not only have employees who are paid to
contribute in the open source Community
we actually take a set of projects and
then you know Harden them we stabilize
them that's what you get with a product
you get life cycle management so that
customers can actually use the version
that best fits their needs and they have
the support needed now so another way to
mitigate support is act the need for
support is to make sure that you're
ahead of the game when it comes comes to
security
what comes to your mind Dan when you
think about security oh there's a lot
that's a hot issue quite honestly and it
can cause quite a panic we've had some
stirs in
problems in brake break-ins and breaches
and stuff like that that can really
drive a company crazy how is it that
this helps in the security to your point
then security is actually a boardroom
topic you know it is not a bunch of
Engineers and you know just hardware and
software or applications thinking about
it it's risk management it is mitigating
risk and you want to be ahead of the
game you want to be ahead of the hackers
so proactive remediation is what I'm
talking about I'm talking about
automated patching so if you if you
leave it to the open source Community
you don't get that type of you know
looking for what is the next
vulnerability what is the next issue
that is likely to crop up what we do is
we have products that would actually you
know track what what uh what types of
remedial measures were taken and apply
artificial intelligence to that so that
we can predict and then also be
proactive about the remediation right so
you and then there is automated
searching for you know different types
of products that we actually provide and
there have been vulnerabilities because
it was manually patched in the open
source community and that's where the
automated patching which you get with
product and you don't with project so
you're saying that's where the value add
where the business value add that other
companies can then offer for open source
project is that kind of the model you're
proposing well to tweak it a little then
the if you are secure on that foundation
with the product you can add business
value with your core competencies you
know maybe you're building a soft drink
or maybe you're flying an airline or
running a bank and you can focus on that
that differentiates your business rather
than worrying about Isis is my platform
secure or not can I focus on the last 10
percent that really delivers value to my
customers exactly got it and so let's
cite a specific example like for example
kubernetes is a project
and openshift is a product
how does the security issue come into
play specifically with it absolutely so
security is not you know so kubernetes
is a library or it's a it's a you know a
set of projects now kubernetes is also
you know there is a reason why it is
getting the traction it is because there
are different companies Google started
it you know Red Hat joined and then now
it is available in across multiple Cloud
providers but there is something to be
said about being compliant no matter
what Hardware vendor you're working with
or which software vendor you are needing
needing to integrate or which you know
hybrid Cloud the cloud provider you're
working with you want to be on a
platform that is secure and compliant no
matter where your applications are
running that is really what makes it a
platform that will allow you to work
with the ecosystem and this also
mitigates risk because then you don't
want to actually you know hit that panic
button for support if you make sure
you're working with the ecosystem you're
certified on Hardware you're compliant
and you're patching and you know you're
secure and with lifecycle management the
chances that you will actually make that
support call you're actually reducing it
you're mitigating risk so strong
Foundation very minimal support only as
needed got it and so the takeaway
message from this is is that open source
is a bus you can get on essentially
Enterprise open source fair enough and
you can ride along but not necessarily
have to drive the bus yes in fact please
don't because it takes multiple
companies not just contributors and open
source is fun let's face it you know
transformation is not just like you know
a week weeks project you know it's not a
destination it's a journey and what we
are transforming to today could change
tomorrow that's where the ride is Fun
the open source ride the Enterprise open
source right excellent and that's a good
note to end on uh so we're going to wrap
with that if you'd like to hear new
topics on Tech talks be sure and drop us
a line below and before you leave please
remember to hit like And subscribe